call of duty war zones mysterious
bunkers have been locked since launch
but as of the latest update they're
finally opening getting in is tricky
especially for bunker 11 so here's what
you need to know there are 11 numbered
bunkers on the warzone map and we're
gonna start with 1 through 10 luckily
these are all opened in the same way to
get inside you'll need a read access
card which can be obtained from a supply
crate of course there's no guarantee
you'll find one inside a crate as the
access card is a very rare item
alternatively you can get one by killing
a player who picked up a card if you
manage to grab one and you make it to a
bunker alive then you're all set with a
read access card in hand you can get
inside bunkers 1 through 10 the doors
will open up and you'll find a ton of
high tier loot waiting for you inside
bunker 11 is a different story though a
read access card won't help you there
instead bunker 11 has its own puzzle
tied into the phones you've probably
seen across the map most of these will
just have a dial tone but one phone will
have a Russian voice speaking on the
other side you'll need to listen to
determine the 3 numbers the voice is
saying here's a handy translation chart
from reddit user stranger Robin once you
confirm the three numbers your squad
needs to split up and head to the
corresponding numbered phones refer to
our map here for the numbers you'll hear
a Morse code pattern playing to confirm
the number of the phone but if you're
using this map you're already good to go
activate those three phones head to
bunker 11 and you're in bunker Elevens
loot is different from all the others
there are lots of supply crates but
you'll also find the mud dauber
blueprint for the mp7 SMG what's more
you can spot a nuke being assembled this
nuke seems to be hinting at the next
Call of Duty game reportedly titled
black ops cold war that's unconfirmed at
this time but you can learn more about
the rumor on GameSpot
you